i will
pass the mic to lieutenant governor dan
patrick
excuse me
excuse me
excuse me
you're out of you're out of line and an
embarrassment
is right now and you are doing nothing
no need to get in
this isn't the place to talk to you this
is totally predictable
sir you're of line
sir you are online
sir you are outlined please leave this
auditorium
[Music]
i can't believe you're a sick son of a
would come to a deal like this to make a
political issue
it's only like you why don't you get out
of here
the governor of the state of texas the
most powerful man in the state chose to
do nothing
he went to santa fe high school after
kids were killed in their classrooms
told the parents he would do something
he did nothing
he came to my hometown of el paso
after 23 people were slaughtered he said
he was going to do something he did
nothing in fact the only thing he did
was make it easier to buy a gun the only
thing he did was make it easier to carry
a gun in public and he bragged about the
fact that there would be no background
check no training
no vetting whatsoever his only interest
is the gun lobby he's scheduled to speak
at the nra convention
this friday in houston texas just days
after these kids were slaughtered right
here in uvalde after they were
slaughtered at santa fe high school at
sutherland springs in midland odessa in
el paso texas five of the worst mass
shootings in u.s history right here in
this state in the last five years he was
governor for every single one of them
and after every one of these he holds a
press conference just like this and i
wish to help when he came to el paso
someone who would have stood up
and held him to account and confronted
him and shocked the conscience of this
state into doing something because if we
do nothing we will continue to see this
year after year school after school kid
after kid
this one is on all of us
it's on every single one of us to do
something